I know you're all jonesing for more Mass  Effect Andromeda details so I'll get  right to it I'm Tony this is a game spot  news update and to catch all the mass  effect news as it trickles out be sure  to subscribe the latest video is all  about exploration according to bioware  there are more than 100 planets and  Andromeda and you can land on a handful  of them to meet alien races and take on  quests we also got a closer look at the  nomad this games version of the Mako  which you'll drive around the planet  surfaces you can upgrade things like  speed and handling and the vehicle can  also be summoned at forward stations  which serve as fast travel points Mass  Effect Andromeda launches on ps4 xbox  one and pc on March 21st for more RPG  goodness you can check out our legend of  zelda breath of the wild review right  now and for all the news from bioware  and mass effect you're already in the  right place  [Music]  you